What I want to do in this video is show you a very cool video, then pose a question.
But I want to make sure that everything is up and up,
in terms of the copyright laws.
So the video I want to show you is from the show called the fifth gear,
that appears on channel 5, I believe in the United Kingdom.
I think I'm okay on good copyright grounds to claim
fair use here, because
obviously the point of this is I'm going to ask a math question
about the vide were going to see
and so fair use
laws
the purpose and character of use
including whether such a commercial nature or non profit educational
purposes we're definitely the later
non profit educational purposes
we are actually
we aren't trying to in any way replace the work being used
I'm just going to show a little snippet of it
so we can use it as the basis for a problem
this is kinda the meat of fair use law
the viewer may fairly cite from the original work if it is
design if his design be really and truly to use the passages
for the purposes for fair and reasonable criticism
in this case
it's fair and reasonable math problem or physics problem
on the other hand it is as clear he thus cites the most important parts of the work. with the view not to criticize
but to supercede the
the use of the original work and substitute
the review for it
such a use will be deemed in law a piracy
so in no way do I want to supersede it. You should go look it up, go watch the show.
this is not good enough
I don't even have the sound on
it's going to be a small window over here
where I'm just going to show this
really really
the part where they actually do a loop
de loop.
now with that out of the way
this is where you can find more about fifth gear
which is on channel 5
so now let me show you the video
I'm going to have the sound down and so this is the video over here
this is a pretty neat video
this guy is going to try to do a loop de loop and he's actually going to succeed
at doing the loop de loop
and what I want you to do, the question I want to pose
is look at this video
and get a stop watch out
or whatever else you need out a ruler whatever else you might need to do
and try to figure out what
we're going to try to figure out two things
we're going to find out the minimum velocity the car needs to do the
loop de loop
and we're also going to try to figure out what his actual velocity was
over the course of the loop de loop
so let's actually just watch this video
so there he goes
he's starting
he's accelerating
it looks like he's
just crossed
he's pushing almost forty miles an hour
at least I'm assuming that's miles per hour
this is a British show
and then he
hits
the loop de loop
and then he finishes it
and he's done
so let's think about for the next video
let's think about if we can figure out what the minimum
what the minimum velocity or i should say the magnitude of the velocity
or the speed had to be
to actually
complete the loop right over here and then we can actually get a stopwatch later on to
see what his actall velocity was